it's almost 25 years since the death of
princess diana in a car crash in paris
her son prince harry is making sure her
charitable working parts of africa lives
on
yesterday the prince played in a charity
polo match at the aspen valley polo club
in colorado to raise funds for
organization he co-founded to help
children in southern africa manuel
bojorquez was at the match and joins us
right now manny good morning
good morning nate as you know prince
harry is involved with several
charitable organizations and events
including the invictus games for wounded
veterans but this annual event held here
at the aspen valley polo club is one
that is clearly close to his heart as he
seeks to carry on his mother's legacy
prince harry arrived at this year's
charity polo match near aspen an event
that's part glitz
part grit all in the name of an
organization he co-founded 16 years ago
inspired by his mother princess diana
sante bale was the name of her favorite
flower and translates into forget me not
the phrase says the centibali
organization reflects its efforts to
bring awareness and support to children
and young people in southern africa
affected by extreme poverty inequality
and hiv aids causes that were near and
dear to his mother it's the kind of work
prince harry has previously highlighted
since body means forget me not um
for the simple case of you know not
forgetting the children and also you
know not not forgetting our mothers who
both princesses and i lost at a fairly
young age
long-time friend and argentinian polo
player nacho figueras spoke to us after
the match tell me how important this
event is for you but also for harry with
the connection to his mother
so i've been involved with this charity
for a very long time the reason it's
because
hari is very committed to it it's
something that's close to his heart the
fact that it is so close to his heart
makes me want to add my grain of sand
it's been nearly 25 years since the
prince lost his mother
and very publicly had to say goodbye as
a stunned world also mourned the loss
since then prince harry has visited some
of the same places his mother did to
continue to raise awareness how have you
seen him grow and evolve into the person
he is today
he's one of my dearest friends i love
that he created a family that was always
his dream to
marry someone that he loves and having
children so i'm very happy to see him at
that stage of his life
prince harry did not make a public
comment at the match but in the event
program there is a statement signed by
the prince and the organization's
co-founder in which they say that as we
approach the anniversary of his mother's
death they quote remember her tireless
work to support and destigmatize those
experiencing hiv aids and we remember
her spirit and her legacy nate
we are oftentimes judged by the fruit we
bear and the apple doesn't far far from
the tree when it comes to prince harry
and his charitable giving manny thank
you